bonsoir à tous en attendant les
résultats la nouvelle donne politique
dans le reste de l'actualité aujourd'hui
tout d'abord le tennis bien sûr avec la
victoire à roland garros de rafael nadal
pour la troisième année consécutive
l'espagnol remporte les internationaux
de france définitivement à terre battue
et le central sont devenu son jardin
julien benedetto jean-marc notebook
il n'y a donc rien à faire face à ce
champion là à 21 ans rafael nadal
remporté pour la troisième année
consécutive roland garros seul bjorn
borg avait réussi cet exploit rêves
brisés pour réduire très derrière qui
devra encore patienter pour remporter le
seul titre du grand chelem qui manque à
son immense palmarès
voilà moi je suis heureux mais un peu
déçu pour rogers elles sont moins grands
paniers c'est un ami il méritait la
victoire
c'est vraiment un grand champion un peu
ça malgré une bonne dizaine de balles de
break contre lui rappelle nadal empoche
le premier set
l'espagnol est fidèle à lui même
toujours aussi stupéfiant physiquement
en face ce n'est pas le grand federer
mais au bout de cette course folle
le numéro un mondial parvient à égaliser
à un set partout
porté par un court central
majoritairement acquis à sa cause
mais le problème est insoluble
avec ses grands coups liftés nadal met
une pression de tous les instants qui
empêche le suisse d'imposer son jeu de
fond de court j'avais peur vraiment
faire ce que je voulais c'est un peu
dommage bien simple on sait ce que j'ai
dans le troisième set nadal se détache
rapidement
c'est le tournant du match federer
baisse la tête comme s'il accepté la
domination de son adversaire après trois
heures de jeu une énième faute directe
du numéro un mondial offre le tournoi au
roi de la terre battue comme l'année
dernière nadal s'impose donc à ce titre
2005 2006 2007 triple couronne pour
l'espagnol
et vu son incroyable niveau de jeu on
voit mal comment cette suprématie
pourrait s'arrêter